hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to shelter now there
was a lot of you guys that actually
wanted to see more of this game and I'm
more than happy to do so I just can't
promise that I'm gonna be any sort of
good or that the appliers are actually
gonna survive which contrary to the name
of the last episode of this series it
may or may not happen wake the Frick up
answer the goddamn radio
wait ah god damn it I've already missed
it I just got back god dammit why is the
bed at 54% integrity how hard have you
[ __ ] been sleeping on it okay so why
are these guys in their bags we got
Barbara down there we got David up here
Stephen and oh god what is her name I
can't even remember the name of my
daughter so he's drinking and he's okay
so what I've done is I've set up
autonomy for these guys since the last
episode which means that they're gonna
generally take care of their needs as
they can get to them but the problem is
that I'm running out of food and I'm
running out of fuel and I'm getting a
lot of water which is good thing because
that means she or he I don't think he
needs to fix it so we should just be
able to give water yeah and that's why I
got all these water buts to be able to
get enough water but what we need now is
food and lots of it and damn it I missed
their expedition thing which probably
means that they had an opportunity to
get goddamn food we're gonna have to cut
up spike and eat his corpse oh it's
horrible
oh god spike I'm so sorry spike I have
no idea spike I'm so sorry I meant to do
goodbye everybody but I'm very new it's
like when I first started subnautica I
don't have a goddamn clue what I'm
supposed to be doing now let's put that
away from now
alright so Dobby Eden can you oh man is
there like an upgrade to the food we
make an upgrade to the food of goddamnit
okay so they got plenty of locations oh
they did get food oh they did get food I
forgot about that did they already come
back in the last one and then the
savegame just came before that I can't
exactly remember okay but we need okay
we need to craft more food storage
because we don't have enough
what oh god damn it nails
ah [ __ ] kids looks like you're gonna
have to go back out there again I'm
sorry it's the only way oh [ __ ] yeah
what's that okay what's going on all
right it's fine
who's there okay all right but at least
let's see Marie are you doing relatively
okay right so Da Vida what is this
something at the journal this diary NR
landed on my feet when we were leaving
the location two's a diary extract for
number forty I'm kind of worried that we
haven't anywhere near enough for
retirement and I keep saying this over
and over but it really gets me down I
know I'm still only 42 but it's going so
quickly oh man well that's sad I mean
it's a hole into the world so what do
you care of our retirement let's get to
tomorrow or whatever Marie you need to
get an expedition going Barbara all
right let's get dahveed
let's get da beat and Marie good
father-daughter time going on here all
right so we need to go to multiple
locations we haven't been nearly enough
and axe holy [ __ ] there's a lot of stuff
out there okay so we need to go to this
petrol station this small house this
church and then we can come back I don't
know what the limitation for going out
is but it seems to be dictated by water
supply which is gonna help us going out
there so the party where that no a coop
okay confirm the coop confirm and send
party okay yep go have fun
don't die that's the important thing
don't be like spike spike was a lesson
to you all
oh god there's a rat in here get out of
here oh oh you went away okay I'm
Barbara so there appears to be a rat can
you steal it for food I guess can you
actually can you clean this [ __ ] up
how do you clean oh boy okay Barbara you
have oh oh oh Barbara Barbara Barbara
except transmission okay
hello Oh Murray here we've stumbled
across a small house and it looks like
it might have some good loot want us to
take a look search the location
okay that's good all right finish what
you were doing on the toilet I guess
[ __ ] except transmission examine items
coffee bean a spring burnt clothes in a
plastic bottle you didn't get goddamn
[ __ ] Marie and why are you in charge I
know you're bossy but it's okay let Davi
do something all right except
transmission hello da feed here we've
stumbled across a fluorescent look like
mine has some good loose I know it's
been raining for a long time okay what
do we got plank of wood no nail metal
seeds
hey seeds oho can I build like it oh I
didn't know I could build a farming
thing that would be incredibly useful oh
man a mannequin arm oh boy I'll be able
to make a fool mannequin in no time I
can't wait to have a newfound friend
when all the rest of my family dies okay
so I don't actually need anyone to do
that I just need to do it myself all
right
god dammit no nails no food oh we're
dying out here
oh good thing I got a pair of pliers for
the appliers
oh your pairs of pliers ragu petrol can
well that's good wait that's a lot of
petrol that's actually really good okay
but all right that's fine
now that's a lot of stuff that we can
have all right except translation oh
they got another one okay what do you
got food yes okay take the I got a lot
of Springs I don't need them and who
needs burnt clothes let's get the food
in here a burnt-out laptop maybe some
recyclable components okay we can do
that all right we got pretty much
everything else that we need okay that's
it I think they're done they should be
coming home pretty soon nope
Wow okay Church out in the wasteland
they're finding a lot of stuff out there
I didn't think that they would you a
family member has lost health they
several ways radiation poisoning
dehydration and malnourished men what do
you need suffocating Oh take off the
goddamn bird why are you doing the suit
how long have you been suffocating in
that suit it's been days Barbara come on
I know you're a robot right now but you
need to be vocal and communicate with
everybody
right wait does that just mean wait a
minute oh no oh no the filters fine
we put there's no power oh that's what
the problem is
oh [ __ ] I have no idea oh [ __ ] okay wait
ah fix Oh God what are you doing where
are you going
what are you doing fix the goddamn thing
you ah add fuel there we go god dammit
how long have we not been doing that
okay search the location good lordy Ron
mr. Tran submission oh god okay it's
fine all right um
we have plenty of metal we could use
these first-aid kits considering we just
suffocated to death we don't need a
plastic bottle but we do need these
antibiotics would be good in case we get
in any trouble okay wiring we could use
that I'm gonna forego the coffee beans
I'm gonna get the let's see I'm gonna
get the wiring cuz we don't have a lot
of that maybe it'll be good well another
one god damn how many things have they
stumbled across out there all right you
need to go we're out of food that's bad
that's bad you're about to starve to
death kid Abhijit that right down there
oh that's fit even I like Steven oh geez
food carry your bag that could be useful
in the future um
scrap pile sand not good for us I'm
gonna get the bag so we can carry more
[ __ ] later I guess that's it get back
home
Steven is starving damn it oh man we
don't have enough we don't have enough
we don't have enough we don't have
enough
Oh No okay hope they get back soon they
better get back here
okay the shower could use with some
repair so fix a shower and you let's see
how much feel we doing as well add fuel
completely out of get back here we need
food shower okay we got that and that
means okay take all no room I mean
there's no room god damn it how much oh
man I gotta make choices for this [ __ ] i
I think I need to salvage this stuff
before I can do anything but I should
have salvaged I'm way before damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
oh my guys are gonna die okay let's
forget the light bulb take the med kits
we need the antibiotics so take out the
okay let's just get rid of the empty
ones for now let's take the dammit god
dammit I need this bag okay I don't know
let's forget the coal forget the coal
for now take the bag so we can get more
in the future
okay alright that's all we can do I need
to get more storage I need to build a
lot more storage Steven stop what you're
doing and freaking eat goddammit stop
you [ __ ] better not take that food
from Steven
Oh David someone does that the intercom
who hell are you Karen new recruits
enter the sheller automated they can be
given jobs but automation cannot be
switched off when they sent cannot be
sent out for expeditions until their
loyalties high enough hi
that's a nice how's about I hop in in
there and join you okay hi Karen did you
jump over some subnautica
what happened to your husband in the
middle of nowhere did you let him drown
probably come on in Karen welcome to the
family so she is another mouth to feed
so we need to send people out on an
expedition like now okay so I'm gonna
send out Stephen okay Karen
I thought Karen couldn't be sent out
okay so we're gonna send out Barbara and
Stephen cuz they need to go do things
okay so they went to a lot of oh they
must have swept across the other houses
first okay okay there we go now that's
too much they can't carry all that [ __ ]
so wait back and we need to no no let's
just go here add air and air and that
should cover enough and be good enough
for us oh no oh no one use only I'll
just give a man out of radiation tablets
and that'll be good that'll offset it
probably yeah it'll be fine Stephen will
be fine he's starving and tired and
probably gonna be laden with radiation
but maybe you'll mutate into something
useful that we can actually utilize in
the future all right Karen a water
filter is starting to fall apart
David oh [ __ ] don't do that we need a
suit
could get a suit then go fix more and
over the loss of spike do you think wait
we got a new diary entry Karen seems to
be a good fit for our shelter everyone
needs to pull their weight if we're
gonna survive so we'll see how this
works out I wonder where Karen came from
and what her life was like before all
this happened did they have some great
stories to tell
I bet not I bet it filled with murdering
of family 'no sand bad stuff like that
probably just a vast diff distance
between the things okay gas masks that's
good
Rach oh boy we can hit people with rock
anyone that comes steal from us it's
mass with rock man do kill them
do-seong we undo bag them in their head
take wife's take food take fire sorry I
got a little too into that well might as
well have some nuisance
metal or okay oh that's what I need to
do I need to recycle the stuff that we
have right now I know that we have some
of those okay so we're gonna okay so
what we need to do we need to open the
storage and we need actually salvaged to
this [ __ ] how do we salvage Karen can
you salvage something craft item um [ __ ]
how do we salvage that's a good question
maybe I should try to learn how to play
the goddamn game but we not though we
need to oh we can build a mop and bucket
that would be nice cuz we don't exactly
whoa okay
sorry you startled me it's a mop and
bucket man there's not a lot of floor
space over here we need someone to dig
more later but that's later so we'll get
to that all right you you build the mop
and bucket so hopefully you can keep
this hope see whoa stumbled across some
wildlife and it looks hungry do you want
us to handle it didn't want to get
involved whoa what's happening Oh what's
this hi oh [ __ ]
well that's not good we're on me rock
we're on rock oh god wait okay attack
huh subdue steal steal from that bear
you better steal Barbara how about you
subdue
oh [ __ ] that ain't good [ __ ] it's over
Smalling Barbara attack me lay this oh
that's oh good whoa Stephen with the
combo damn holy [ __ ] Barbara you're a
beast this fedora
alright Mele okay that's nice that's
cool too okay Stephen you're a brave
little kid I got it oh alright well kill
that bear with our bare hands here meat
okay that's good
all right besides of the minor bear
wounds that we suffer maybe we'll just
get a bottle of Barrow ointment while
we're out here cover him up with bear
bandages I will be alive that was my
first battle I didn't even know that
there was a battle system in this game
all right clean shelter please Karen
pull your weight clean the goddamn
shelter can you kill that bunny [ __ ] are
you okay search that who the [ __ ] are
you Gregory you better not come in here
because we don't have enough food for
everybody
oh god damn it we don't have enough we
can't do it just can't do it okay tier
two satchel that would be nice tripwire
bedroll carrier bag bandages to stop
bleeding I have a funny feeling we're
gonna need those because I'm pretty sure
if Tevan is still bleeding what are you
doing in here go away Gregory and except
transmission yep passion flower oh I
don't know if we need that what did you
find
wait where did they go I didn't even
read
I'm sorry Gregory I'll be right with you
we don't have we can't can't do it sorry
can't do it okay sorry we need to get
rid of some shelter stuff before they
come back
Gregory help I'm being chased by
something let me in please I need
somewhere safe to stay no Gregory I'm
sorry we're at full capacity and we got
no frickin food sorry
goodbye am I gonna watch this guy get
brutally murdered probably we got some
food on the way but we don't have any
way to cook it I don't know how to cook
it is there any way we can craft like a
like a stove or something an incinerator
stable oh that would have been nice well
that would have been real nice for a
spike if I'd have known about that hmm
poor stove a hinge hinge oh man oh [ __ ]
oh god I just found out the term is
recycling not salvaging and you need to
build a recycling plant to do that and
it takes four in-game hours to do
something so I can't even recycle these
I don't even need these things in my
thing to recycle I can't do anything
about him yet so I need to keep getting
new stuff and hopefully I don't know how
but I need to get hinges so that I can
get this stuff in order and I probably
have seen hinges before I just didn't
know that was something that I needed oh
they're gonna starve but they we're
where are the brother guys where's the
rest of my family oh there they are Oh
No Oh kill that elk kill it kill the
weird skull-faced elk the skin and bones
elk kill it ah [ __ ] Steven ain't feeling
so good because I believed it
Steven is bleeding take all no no those
are the things that we need I'm not
gonna leave those behind okay so
oh I don't have any freezers for the
meat oh man
we just have honey and you can't eat
that
god dammit are you huh let me let me
just see nope
you need a freezer for it I didn't know
that son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] well [ __ ] we
got no [ __ ] food so what we need to
do is we need to send people out like
okay what first Steven you need to take
Vantage's and fix yourself up cuz I know
you're bleeding
lady are you bleeding okay we need to
set up another expedition with dahveed
and Marie Marie is hungry she's probably
gonna starve on the way out there we
just need to we just got to go to these
things again oh [ __ ] we don't have
enough water oh my god are you kidding
me
really oh no oh no we're fine oh we're
fine
oh we're
oh we're [ __ ]
oh no we are [ __ ] I was not paying
water yes we got water pray we can do an
expedition
everyone's gonna starve yeah why bye
well here we go have an expedition I
guess oh boy they're gonna die we're
gonna die in here they're gonna die out
there everyone's gonna die oh this is
not looking good
he's not looking good man what I wanted
to come back in this series I told you
guys it wasn't gonna be good not gonna
be good
one of your character is mal nurse they
would tell man Ohno I know I know
get involved oh they want to talk okay
let's talk to him considering we're
about to die anyway that's a good option
hello hi stranger oh now what brings
someone like you to my door confirm I
don't know confirm hey just passing very
well favors for favors let us spread our
fares and barter I don't have anything
all right goodbye aw damn I thought it
was gonna be my lucky day
maybe next time okay good enough goodbye
nice hanging man in the background all
right what are you a food one one piece
of food better than nothing better than
nothing you know it's interesting the
music in this game reminds me of it's
the weirdest connection it reminds me of
Deus Ex the original one like the very
first deus ex that ever came out or days
ex or whatever you want to call it the
music in there it was like some
electronic a techno is supposed to be
futuristic and stuff because the game
polluted place way in the future and
it's just for some reason I'm getting
those vibes from it I don't know why
it's kind of cool I like it I dig it one
more food just one we're crawling by
we're not gonna have enough food but
we've crawlin
I I don't think they're gonna be back
before everyone dies brooch strangers oh
boy I didn't even read that that was a
small pharmacy approach strangers this
is gonna end well
hi skin colors a little weird hey hello
confirm bully bully
hey look we both know only one of us
leaving this don't we oh [ __ ]
that's not what I wanted ah [ __ ] ah well
me I'm hit with rock me I'm hit Marie
with Marie Marie Marie only one Marie
leaves two Marie Auner
only one Marie leaves with rock with
rock you can't withstand our rocks like
father like son
oh [ __ ] like father like son we fail ow
ow ow
man that Marie doesn't like the other
Marie I don't know how you caused her to
bleed but like oh man Marie killed Marie
breathe Chuck Marie now okay I was
ridiculous yeah Marie you level up a
little more trauma but not much for a
little girl she's used to murder oh we
got strangers again Marie still bleeding
so I hope it doesn't turn to violence
hello hi Pamela hello there don't panic
see I'll move slow uh trade I'll screw
it screw it screw you two just cut me
when you're done and take that too what
I just want what are you talking about
I just wanted to trade okay never mind
then you have lovely day now well you
just looked at get forth right in the
mouth didn't you
I don't know Oh what the hell happened
there I don't know what the hell I
didn't have you didn't have anything I
wanted one more can of food but this is
not looking good I mean that's one can
of food for everybody technically I just
don't know if they're gonna get back in
time before one nail I need a nail what
knife that'd be cool sand we don't need
that okay we're done let me just check
storage again to see if there's anything
else I can do them before they get back
I mean I get I guess I could dump fuel
are they coming back
this must be the return trip they must
be coming back pretty soon
oh it's not gonna be soon enough oh it's
not gonna be soon enough
oh it's not a crude take the food get
the food yes yes okay they got it we
don't have the knife but that's okay we
have got Rock we am get Rock we don't
need Rock yeah we don't need the honey
either let's take the knife nice better
than rock with pliers don't need rock no
more rock em jerk metal not sure shark
okay eat eat for the love of goodness
gracious eat right now no no you eat eat
food you too don't go over there I'm not
staying here to take this kind of abuse
I'd better be good bye great
that leaves one extra food that is so
good oh that's so good oh yes the pliers
have survived goodbye Karen we didn't
need you anyway it wasn't gonna be good
we weren't bonding I mean you didn't
even mourn over the dead corpse of our
horse spike I mean we're [ __ ] but
come on come on we got into trouble on
our expedition we really wanted to run
but they gave us no choice it was
terrible who's either author then I was
so scared you mean now we taunted them
and then murdered them and then took
their stuff probably okay so there are
quests - huh wait wasn't Murray bleeding
take care of that I guess how about you
use a first aid pack you to use a first
aid Jesus
how about Davi EDA dahveed's all right
Murray's all rights Stephens about to be
alright okay okay okay we're doing okay
I'm shocked we're out that was really
close but we made it through I know that
we need to expedite more to the recent
locations and we need to get more food
food is priority we cannot survive
without food as is obvious but oh man I
don't know how much longer we're gonna
be able to survive but for right now
we're doing great so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know if you
want to see even more of this I wouldn't
mind starting a new series of this game
it's really fun there's something really
interesting about the element of
survival that people really like
identify with like I love this that's
why people love zombie apocalypses so
much because they love the struggle like
the drama of it like the dire situations
are really fun so I mean not fun for
them but me as the Overlord controlling
all of them totally fine with me so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
a drug trip one of us guys whatever